we're all being urged by the government
to drive electric but just how ready is
the technology for us to make the switch
from petrol and diesel
to test it i'm driving 400 miles from
london to the climate change summit in
glasgow
philippa oldham is a propulsion engineer
and she's joining me for the first leg
of my journey north a nissan leaf for
example back in 2013
your range of that vehicle would be
between 80 and 90 miles now they're
saying that the latest generation is
about 240 real real driving so how close
are we to having electric vehicles that
can replace a petrol or diesel i think
you know we're there you know people are
now choosing to buy electric but there's
still lots of people who aren't buying
ones i think a lot of people would buy
electric
and i think that they just can't afford
the price at the moment i've dropped
philippa off and it's time to top up the
battery
but then my day starts to unravel what
does that mean charging is delayed until
power is available
communication problems make sure car is
turned off
and then retry
the car is off
with several attempts and some help it
finally works it's charging
how long
hopefully hopefully but one of the other
chargers is on the blink and dion and
sirosh who've been driving electric for
several months say it's not unusual
there's a lot of work to do if they plan
on having is it scrapping all diesel
cars by 2030
it's nowhere near ready if they've only
got two i mean they've got two charging
spots here they need at least 10 here i
think it's the future
it's it's better for the environment but
all this stress and headache i might
have gone by diesel car petrol car
because at least then i know there's
going to be fuel at the petrol station
i'm back on the road mulling over the
numbers there are just over 26 000
public charges in the uk but one in 10
rapid charges doesn't work at any given
time on average and to meet demand the
uk needs as many as 450 thousand extra
charges by twenty thirty
three hours of stop start traffic later
it's time for another top up
out of order
can we this is long enough i can't see
what i'm doing
so
i mean this is so poorly lit that's not
taking payment
this is nuts
how are we supposed to rely on machines
where one's not working
this one will only supply power to one
car when it's got two power cables
this would not happen if i'd driven a
petrol car
it's exasperating we need electric cars
i risk driving on to the next charger
with just 45 miles of juice left it's
preparing to charge
it's charging
grid serve which operates the machines
we used said it was expanding the
network of high power charges and
upgrading them so they can top up two
cars at the same time it added that
problems in charging can be caused by
the car or poor cable connection as well
as the charger itself
by the time we reach glasgow it's almost
midnight
well that's been a long drive and to be
perfectly honest the car has been great
in many respects it's better to drive
than a petrol or diesel um
certainly the range hasn't been a
problem it's nice and quiet
great but the problem has been the the
charging network which really isn't up
to what we need if we're going to go net
zero it's not range anxiety you'll have
it's charger anxiety and that is a
problem they need to crack
the government says it is investing more
in the charging network but will it come
fast enough
thomas more sky news glasgow